[torch hissing]
[saw scraping]
[file scratching]
My name is Macy,
and I am a jeweler at Maejean Vintage.
I am going to walk you through
how to restore a 1930s art deco ring.
This ring is a 14-karat
yellow gold setting.
The gemstone in this ring
is a created spinel stone.
The biggest things wrong with this ring
were the misshapen band,
there's a resizing bar
at the bottom of the ring band
from the previous resizing,
and then the gemstone
will need to be replaced,
as it's not in any salvageable condition.
This ring might probably
only be worth maybe $100,
and when we're finished,
this ring might sell for
about $4,000 to $5,000.
The first thing that I will
do with any restoration
is to take out any gemstones
that can't be saved.
There's a large part on
the underside of this stone
that had cracked off.
I am getting rid of the resizing band
because oftentimes,
especially in vintage and antique pieces,
the resizing was often poorly done.
This tool is called a jeweler's saw,
and I'm using this to
cut out the sizing bar
rather than unsoldering it,
just because I was having
some trouble unsoldering it.
So just to be safe and
eliminate the chance
of accidentally melting the whole ring
while trying to unsolder it,
I just decided to cut it out.
Soldering is a process
of joining two pieces
of metal with solder,
and that solder can be either
silver solder or gold solder.
When I remove that piece of metal,
solder will only flow
if it's a perfect seam.
So once I cut the sizing bar out,
I have to file the ends
so they're perfectly
parallel to each other
so that when I close that seam
there's no air in between,
so that the solder can flow.
[file scratching]
I am hammering the seam shut,
so I'm trying to close
those two ends together.
Even if the ring band
isn't perfectly round,
that can always be fixed later,
as long as those two ends
are touching each other
to get them ready to be
soldered back together.
And then I take the ring
to my soldering bench,
and I'm going to prep
the ring for soldering.
I apply what is called flux,
and flux will prevent any oxides
that will form on the surface of the ring
while being soldered from
the torch from building up,
and then adding my gold solder to the seam
where I intend to have it flow.
Then I'm going to be using
a 14-karat-gold solder,
which is essentially just an
alloy of gold and also zinc,
and zinc is what makes the
metal melt at a low temperature.
So it allows the solder
to flow into the seam
of what I'm trying to connect,
and it will bind those two
pieces together permanently.
And then I use my torch to
evenly heat up the piece
in order to get the solder up
to its melting temperature.
[torch hissing]
The prongs on this ring are
cracked and worn from age.
They just need a little
bit of reinforcement.
I add some solder to the prongs
to give them some extra thickness
so I can create a new seat
later on in the process for the stone.
[torch hissing]
[flex shaft buzzing]
Once I'm finished with the prongs,
I take the ring back to my bench
and remove some of the
extra solder material
from the inside of the ring band.
I use a tool called a flex shaft
with a silicone bit,
and that's going to remove
some of the material from the solder seam
so that when I hammer it round again,
the solder doesn't embed
itself into the metal.
Once that material is mostly removed,
I move on to hammering
a round shape back into the ring
with a rawhide mallet
and a steel ring mandrel.
And since the steel
ring mandrel is tapered
to accommodate for all different
kinds of sizes of rings,
I frequently flip back and forth
and work from both sides to make sure
that one side is not
larger than the other side,
and I work from all sides of the piece
except for on the ring head,
because I don't want to
deform the head of the ring.
Once I'm done rounding the band back out,
I go ahead and I start
removing some of the solder
from the outside of the band,
and I use this with the hand file.
And then once I'm finished
with the hand file,
I start using some
silicone polishing wheels
with my Foredom flex shaft
to further remove some of the scratches
and begin the process of
starting to polish the piece.
We go through a process of
four different abrasivenesses,
starting from the most
coarse to the finest,
to get the bulk of the polishing done
on the outside of the piece.
Once I'm done working on the ring band,
I move on to polishing
the inside of the ring,
starting with a polishing compound
that's called White Diamond.
And this is an abrasive
polishing compound,
so even though it's polishing,
it still removes material
from the surface of the metal.
And then, after that,
I move on to a polishing
compound called Fabulustre,
which is a polishing compound
that is very tiny clay bits,
so it kind of brings out that really
luster, high-polish finish to the metal.
And once I'm done with that,
I repeat the entire process
on the outside of the ring
so that I can get the ring
back to a mirror finish,
like it should be.
[polishing tool buzzing]
Once I'm done with polishing,
I move on to getting the
stone ready to be set.
I'm replacing the created
spinel with a diamond,
because it's a large enough setting
that it would make a really
nice engagement ring.
It's a solid ring setting.
This diamond is 1.3 carats.
To prepare for the diamond to be set,
I kind of evaluate where
all the prongs are at,
I make sure that they're all even,
they're all nice and reinforced
from the soldering that
I have already done,
and I start to carve out the material
with some setting burrs and ball burrs
to try and create a more perfect seat
for the diamond to sit in.
Once that's done,
I use a little bit of wax
to place the stone into the ring setting.
And from there, since it's a good fit,
I'm ready to start
pushing the prongs over,
and so I use a tool that
is called a bezel pusher
to start to push over the prongs
to hold the diamond in place.
We are so happy with
how this ring came out.
We're so happy to give it a second life.